on the occasion of president Trump's
Asia trip those who have spent a
lifetime singing from the globalist
hymnal are now suddenly American
Exceptionalist those who presided over
the decline of America's standing in the
world now say Trump is doing this whole
foreign policy thing wrong especially
when it comes to China here's the
president earlier today both the United
States and China will have a more
prosperous future if we can achieve a
level economic playing field right now
unfortunately it is a very one-sided and
unfair one we talk often it's a very
good chemistry between the two of us
I don't blame China
after all who can blame a country for
being able to take advantage of another
country for the benefit of its citizens
I give China great credit the former
Secretary of State Madeleine Albright
did not like that at all
he is not the center of everything that
happens I am appalled at the way that
this is being presented and that the way
that the president talks about himself
and those who are trying to help him is
it dangerous not to have these positions
filled or would it just be better I
think it's dangerous I do like her
brooch I like that brooch
Oh Madeleine it's interesting to see a
lecture somebody about their conduct
abroad now where did you learn your
statecraft was it from Assad
how about was it from Putin or maybe it
was your time with Kim jong-il I guess
you could call that sick of Fanta cut I
guess it's more aptly described as just
plain old diplomacy what did she want
President Trump to do take his shoe off
and pound the table and the Great Hall
of course if President President Trump
actually used the occasion to really
rail against the Chinese Albright and
company would be slamming him for being
uncouth and unprofessional the
consummate Ugly American and then Team
Obama chimed in here's his former
ambassador to China Chris Hill is there
a chance that he is kowtow to the
Chinese leader in small part because
he's trying to get the big deal in North
Korea I think to some extent that's what
he's looking for but frankly that's now
not how we're gonna get Chinese
cooperation by countering to them we
need to explain to the Chinese why this
issue is important to us why the China
relationship is important to us and why
we need to work together on this
countering at least you didn't literally
bow down like someone else we know I
still love that shot there's something
deliciously ironic about headlines such
as this from slate today weak and
clueless Trump is the American president
of Chinese Dreams there it is
think about what happened to the United
States visa V China during Obama's two
terms in office just for a second the
trade deficit ballooned every single
year American ideas and technologies
were stolen China built islands for
military use in international waters
China expanded their economic footprint
from Africa all the way to Argentina and
everywhere in between they poured
hundreds of billions of dollars into
their army which is now larger than our
army it's standing army larger than ours
and by the way their human rights abuses
the religious abuses they proliferated
so no one who is not overtly anti-trump
would believe for a second that the
Chinese think Trump is weaker as an
adversary than Obama gino's President
Trump does not buy into the whole
citizen of the world claptrap of the
bushes and Obama's he knows that Trump
is an unabashedly ver in American
exceptionalism and by the way that's a
market contrast to how President Obama
sounded remember back at that 2009 NATO
summit I believe in American
exceptionalism just as I suspect that
the Brits believe in British
exceptionalism and the Greeks believe in
Greek exceptionalism and she knows that
Trump would never prostrate himself and
apologize for America either the early
decisions that we've made that you're
starting to see some restoration of
America's standing in the world there
have been times where America has shown
arrogance and been dismissive even
derisively the United States is still
working through some of our own darker
periods in our history we have at times
been disengaged and at times we've
sought to dictate our terms the bottom
line is this a lot of the armchair
quarterbacks have needled the
president's every move in Asia from koi
ponds to Japanese cars but before we
start taking advice from the people who
ran American prestige and power into a
ditch maybe we should consider that
was doing something different he's
projecting American power with a lighter
touch and he's actually connected
culturally with the Chinese by honoring
their history and appreciating their
hospitality now that might not be a bad
idea it might not be a bad opening for
tough trade and strategic negotiations
ahead we'll see he's also in a
surprisingly understated way put down
the marker that he will defend the
rights of the American people and he did
that in Asia something everyone should
be cheering and that's the angle